Hello. Hi there. Welcome to a very special Friday episode of Office Ladies. It is Friday, but it is not Friday chit-chat. It's a little something different. You all know that the long-awaited, much-anticipated television show, The Paper, is premiering on Peacock's September 4th. And, as you also know, we got exclusive access to the set. you know, there are going to be 10 episodes of the paper. I think we visited somewhere around
Hello. Hi there. Welcome to a very special Friday episode of Office Ladies. It is Friday, but it is not Friday chit-chat. It's a little something different. You all know that the long-awaited, much-anticipated television show, The Paper, is premiering on Peacock's September 4th. And, as you also know, we got exclusive access to the set. you know, there are going to be 10 episodes of the paper. I think we visited somewhere around|||大家好。嗨。欢迎收听《办公室女士》一个非常特别的周五单集。今天是周五，但这可不是周五闲聊。这是点儿不一样的东西。大家都知道，备受期待、翘首以盼的电视剧《The Paper》将于 9 月 4 日在 Peacock 首播。而且，如你们所知，我们获得了独家探班剧组的机会。你知道，这部剧总共有 10 集。我想我们去探班的时候大概拍到了
episode eight. And we brought along our portable microphone and we got interviews with several cast members. We weren't able to interview everyone, unfortunately, because people were in scenes. So we were pulling people in and out of scenes, but we did get to talk to a lot of folks. So in anticipation of the premiere next month, we are going to start dropping those cast interviews every Friday. So today, we are going to get to hear a from Donal Gleason. You might know him from his movies X. Machina or as General Hux in Star Wars Rise of the Resistance. He also starred in the miniseries The Patient with Steve Carell and the movie Fountain of Youth with John Krasinski. This is such a fun interview. He talks all about his character on the paper and his experience shooting the show.
episode eight. And we brought along our portable microphone and we got interviews with several cast members. We weren't able to interview everyone, unfortunately, because people were in scenes. So we were pulling people in and out of scenes, but we did get to talk to a lot of folks. So in anticipation of the premiere next month, we are going to start dropping those cast interviews every Friday. So today, we are going to get to hear a from Donal Gleason. You might know him from his movies X. Machina or as General Hux in Star Wars Rise of the Resistance. He also starred in the miniseries The Patient with Steve Carell and the movie Fountain of Youth with John Krasinski. This is such a fun interview. He talks all about his character on the paper and his experience shooting the show.|||第八集左右。我们带上了便携式麦克风，采访了几位演员。不幸的是，我们没能采访到每个人，因为大家都在拍戏。所以我们是在大家拍戏的间隙把人拉过来采访的，但我们确实和很多人聊了聊。因此，为了迎接下个月的首播，我们将从每个周五开始发布这些演员采访。所以今天，我们将听到多姆纳尔·格里森的访谈。你可能通过他的电影《机械姬》或《星球大战：抵抗组织的崛起》中的赫克斯将军认识他。他还与史蒂夫·卡瑞尔共同主演了迷你剧《病人》，并与约翰·卡拉辛斯基合作了电影《青春之泉》。这是一场非常有趣的访谈。他详细谈到了他在《The Paper》中的角色以及拍摄该剧的经历。
We were so tickled to meet him. Oh my gosh. Okay. The other thing we wanted to let you all know is that we only had one microphone. So you might hear us passing our single microphone back and forth a little, but our friends at Odyssey did a great job cleaning up the sound. You know, we really did this with that sort of man-on-the-street style feel. Yes. We were like, on-the-fly reporters. Yes, with our one microphone. Well, we are just so excited to finally get to share these with you. And very soon, Greg said we could get an early access sneak peek of the show. They are going to send us a screener for the paper.
We were so tickled to meet him. Oh my gosh. Okay. The other thing we wanted to let you all know is that we only had one microphone. So you might hear us passing our single microphone back and forth a little, but our friends at Odyssey did a great job cleaning up the sound. You know, we really did this with that sort of man-on-the-street style feel. Yes. We were like, on-the-fly reporters. Yes, with our one microphone. Well, we are just so excited to finally get to share these with you. And very soon, Greg said we could get an early access sneak peek of the show. They are going to send us a screener for the paper.|||见到他我们太高兴了。天哪。好的。我们要告诉大家的另一件事是，我们只有一个麦克风。所以你们可能会听到我们俩把这唯一一个麦克风传来传去的声音，但 Odyssey 的朋友们在音频清理方面做得非常棒。你知道，我们做这个采访确实有一种街头采访的风格。是的。我们就像是即兴记者。是的，就拿着我们这一个麦克风。总之，我们非常高兴终于能把这些分享给你们。而且很快，格雷格说我们可以提前抢先观看这部剧。他们会给我们寄一份《The Paper》的内部审看集。
I know. That's right. We're going to watch it and do a breakdown of the pilot episode. So, be on the lookout for that too. But now, here's our chat with Donald Gleeson. All right. Hello. Will you please tell us your name and your character name? My name is Donal Gleeson and I'm playing Ned Sampson in the paper. Can you tell us a little bit about your character and what your role is in the world of the paper? Sure. So Ned, as the series begins, is arriving at the paper. So the first day that the documentary crew arrive at the paper is Ned's first day on the job. And he is arriving to be the new editor in chief of the paper. He is very low on experience, but high on intensity and intention and
I know. That's right. We're going to watch it and do a breakdown of the pilot episode. So, be on the lookout for that too. But now, here's our chat with Donald Gleeson. All right. Hello. Will you please tell us your name and your character name? My name is Donal Gleeson and I'm playing Ned Sampson in the paper. Can you tell us a little bit about your character and what your role is in the world of the paper? Sure. So Ned, as the series begins, is arriving at the paper. So the first day that the documentary crew arrive at the paper is Ned's first day on the job. And he is arriving to be the new editor in chief of the paper. He is very low on experience, but high on intensity and intention and|||我知道。没错。我们要看这部剧并对试播集进行剖析。所以，大家也敬请期待那个节目吧。但现在，我们要播放的是我们与多姆纳尔·格里森的聊天。好了。你好。能请你告诉我们你的名字和你的角色名吗？我叫多姆纳尔·格里森，我在《The Paper》里饰演内德·桑普森。你能给我们简单介绍一下你的角色以及你在《The Paper》的世界里扮演什么角色吗？当然。剧集一开始，内德就来到了这家报社。所以纪录片摄制组来到报社的第一天，也是内德上班的第一天。他是来担任这家报社的新任总编辑的。他没什么经验，但干劲十足、目标明确，而且
hope. It's quite an optimistic person. And he arrives into a place. it's not all that enthused about being a paper. And he wants to make it something special. That's his idea. What is his relationship to the documentary being done? I think he likes the notion that the documentary crew are around because it means if there are good moments, they're there for posterity.
hope. It's quite an optimistic person. And he arrives into a place. it's not all that enthused about being a paper. And he wants to make it something special. That's his idea. What is his relationship to the documentary being done? I think he likes the notion that the documentary crew are around because it means if there are good moments, they're there for posterity.|||充满希望。他是一个相当乐观的人。他来到了一个地方，那里的人对办报纸并不是那么热情。而他想把它打造成一档特别的节目。这就是他的想法。他对正在拍摄的纪录片有什么看法？我觉得他挺喜欢纪录片摄制组在周围转悠这个概念的，因为这意味着如果有美好的时刻被记录下来，它们就会流传后世。
And if there are bad moments, I think it probably heightens his awareness of how bad it feels. we always ask everyone how they got their job like on the office their sort of audition story can you share with us how you got your job on the paper it was great they sent me the first script and um i asked if i wanted to chat and i said sure and i talked to them for i think 20 minutes and um i think i thought maybe they were sort of interviewing me and then when i was chatting to them it felt more like they thought i was interviewing them i don't if felt like funny that way and then they offered me their part. It's great. What over these 10 episodes can you share with us that I don't know any moments, any storylines that you've enjoyed or have been a challenge, anything at all? Well, I think we're kind of doing it. I think his relationship to the paper is the most important thing. I think in a way he's got a lot of romance about what it is to be a part of a paper and what it should be, despite overwhelming odds and the fact
And if there are bad moments, I think it probably heightened his awareness of how bad it feels. we always ask everyone how they got their job like on the office their sort of audition story can you share with us how you got your job on the paper it was great they sent me the first script and um i asked if i wanted to chat and i said sure and i talked to them for i think 20 minutes and um i think i thought maybe they were sort of interviewing me and then when i was chatting to them it felt more like they thought i was interviewing them i don't if felt like funny that way and then they offered me their part. It's great. What over these 10 episodes can you share with us that I don't know any moments, any storylines that you've enjoyed or have been a challenge, anything at all? Well, I think we're kind of doing it. I think his relationship to the paper is the most important thing. I think in a way he's got a lot of romance about what it is to be a part of a paper and what it should be, despite overwhelming odds and the fact|||而如果有什么糟糕的时刻，我想这可能会加剧他对这种糟糕感觉的体会。我们总是问每个人是怎么得到工作的，就像在《办公室》里那样，问问他们的试镜故事。你能跟我们分享一下你是怎么得到《The Paper》里的工作的吗？这太棒了，他们把第一集剧本发给了我，嗯……他们问我想不想聊聊，我说好啊。我和他们聊了大概 20 分钟，嗯……我觉得当时我可能以为他们是在面试我，但后来在和他们聊天的过程中，感觉更像是他们觉得我在面试他们。我不知道，那种感觉挺逗的，然后他们就让我演了这个角色。这太棒了。在这 10 集当中，有什么能跟我们分享的吗？比如说我不知道的某些时刻、你很喜欢的或者觉得很有挑战性的故事情节，随便什么都可以？嗯，我觉得我们现在其实就是在聊这个。我认为他对报社的态度是最重要的。在某种程度上，他对成为报社的一员以及报社应该是什么样子抱有许多浪漫的幻想，尽管面临着压倒性的困难，以及这样一个事实：
that the newspaper industry, on the most part, is dying. So trying to like do something that's where you can still be hopeful and still be intelligent in some ways and yet enough to undercut it and find the humor in all of that. I think that's been the journey. On the office, we were encouraged to do improvisation. We were encouraged to pitch ideas to the writers. Is it that same kind of environment here? I mean, it feels like we're only 10 episodes, right, for the first season. And they're pretty, the office was almost secretly plotted.
that the newspaper industry, on the most part, is dying. So trying to like do something that's where you can still be hopeful and still be intelligent in some ways and yet enough to undercut it and find the humor in all of that. I think that's been the journey. On the office, we were encouraged to do improvisation. We were encouraged to pitch ideas to the writers. Is it that same kind of environment here? I mean, feels like we're only 10 episodes, right, for the first season. And they're pretty, the office was almost secretly plotted.|||报纸行业在很大程度上正在消亡。所以，努力去做这样一件事：在其中你仍然可以抱有希望，在某些方面仍然充满智慧，但又足以打破这种沉闷，并在这一切中找到幽默感。我想这就是这段旅程。在《办公室》里，我们被鼓励进行即兴表演。我们被鼓励向编剧提出想法。这里的环境也是这样的吗？我的意思是，感觉第一季只有 10 集，对吧？而且它们的节奏挺……《办公室》的剧情几乎是秘密编排的。
When you watch episodes of the office, they don't feel like plot heavy or story heavy. They feel very character driven. even though there is a lot of story holding all that up. On this one, I think there's almost like a lot of the time it's the story of the week in terms of they're chasing down in particular story or whatever like that. So actually there's quite a lot of story points to get across in every scene. So I think that the improv, it's really fun when we get to do it,
When you watch episodes of the office, they don't feel like plot heavy or story heavy. They feel very character driven. even though there is a lot of story holding all that up. On this one, I think there's almost like a lot of the time it's the story of the week in terms of they're chasing down in particular story or whatever like that. So actually there's quite a lot of story points to get across in every scene. So I think that the improv, it's really fun when we get to do it,|||当你观看《办公室》的剧集时，它们并不让人觉得情节很重或故事很重。它们感觉非常注重塑造人物。尽管有大量的剧情在支撑着这一切。但在这一部里，我感觉很多时候它就像是每周故事，他们是在追查某个特定的故事诸如此类的东西。所以实际上每个场景中都有相当多的故事要点需要传达。因此我认为即兴表演，当我们能做的时候真的很有趣，
but actually there's a load of information that needs to come out in every scene. And so I think it feels so far out the tracks might be a little bit more set. Maybe that's more for NAD. I think for my character than for other people, because he's trying to push that stuff forward. But I could be wrong on that. I'm not sure. No, I get that. My character usually had something very specific.
but actually there's a load of information that needs to come out in every scene. And so I think it feels so far out the tracks might be a little bit more set. Maybe that's more for NAD. I think for my character than for other people, because he's trying to push that stuff forward. But I could be wrong on that. I'm not sure. No, I get that. My character usually had something very specific.|||但实际上每个场景中都有大量的信息需要抛出来。所以我觉得到目前为止，轨道可能会稍微固定一点。也许这对内德来说更是如此。我觉得比起其他人，对我的角色来说更是这样，因为他在努力推动那些事情向前发展。但我可能搞错了。我不太确定。不，我懂的。我的角色通常有一些非常具体的东西。
She had to give to the scene. And so if I ever got an improv in, it would be at the very top or the very end when I was already done giving information. And I think some characters, that's their role, is they come in, they have a purpose and then they don't hang out as much. Mine did. I know it is a bigger role. But I still got very excited when one or two would make it in. Um, I mean, I feel like we improvised a lot and a lot of that improvisation never saw the light of day. So there was there, but there was just that feeling of fun on, on, yes, that then would seep into the scripted work.
She had to give to the scene. And so if I ever got an improv in, it would be at the very top or the very end when I was already done giving information. And I think some characters, that's their role, is they come in, they have a purpose and then they don't hang out as much. Mine did. I know it is a bigger role. But I still got very excited when one or two would make it in. Um, I mean, I feel like we improvised a lot and a lot of that improvisation never saw the light of day. So there was there, but there was just that feeling of fun on, on, yes, that then would seep into the scripted work.|||她必须在场景中表达出来。所以如果我加入任何即兴表演，它都会发生在最开始或者最后，也就是我已经讲完信息之后。而且我认为有些角色，他们的职责就是这样：他们出场，带着一个目的，然后就不会待太久。我的角色不是这样。我知道这是一个更大的角色。但当有一两个即兴发挥最终被采用时，我还是会非常兴奋。嗯，我的意思是，我觉得我们做了很多即兴表演，其中很多即兴表演从未见天日。所以它们在那里，但那种有趣的赶脚，是的，会渗透到剧本的工作中去。
Because we would play around at the top or play around at the bottom of a scene. Yeah. I think that's the ideal scenario as well. But it's also like, it's also the sketch. man, like is full on. And so we're squishing a lot, you know, there are 42 page scripts, you know, so it's like we're getting a lot or can be between 38 and 42 for the most part. And I know, I know it's similar for everybody, but like there's a lot, just in a day, there's a lot to get through. So my favorite days are the days where like the dynamic of the scene is clear from the top and you can play in that sort of sample. Like that's where you know where you are and then you can really bounce things around or group scenes. There's a lot of
Because we would play around at the top or play around at the bottom of a scene. Yeah. I think that's the ideal scenario as well. But it's also like, it's also the sketch. man, like is full on. And so we're squishing a lot, you know, there are 42 page scripts, you know, so it's like we're getting a lot or can be between 38 and 42 for the most part. And I know, I know it's similar for everybody, but like there's a lot, just in a day, there's a lot to get through. So my favorite days are the days where like the dynamic of the scene is clear from the top and you can play in that sort of sample. Like that's where you know where you are and then you can really bounce things around or group scenes. There's a lot of|||因为我们会在一个场景的开头或结尾即兴胡闹。是的。我认为这也是最理想的情况。但这也是……这也是个小品剧。天哪，比如工作强度太满了。所以我们压缩了很多内容，你知道的，剧本有 42 页，所以这就好比我们要拍很多东西，大多数情况下页数在 38 到 42 页之间。我知道，我知道对每个人来说都差不多，但比如有很多内容，仅仅在一天之内，就有大量的东西要拍完。所以我最喜欢的日子是那种：场景的活力从一开始就很明确，你可以在那种样本里尽情发挥。就好像你知道自己在哪里，然后你就可以真正地把事情抛来抛去或者组合场景。有很多
that. And then, yeah, it just depends on the scene. But I'm also just still getting to know it. It's a new process for me. This is an ad by BetterHelp. You know, it feels like nowadays there's advice for just about everything. It's like, do you write in your journal? Do you do, I don't know, cleanses or the cold plunge or, you know, what helps you get through the day? What helps you get through stressful moments? Mm-hmm. For me, it's talking it out. Mm-hmm.
that. And then, yeah, just depends on the scene. But I'm also just still getting to know it. It's a new process for me. This is an ad by BetterHelp. You know, it feels like nowadays there's advice for just about everything. It's like, do you write in your journal? Do you do, I don't know, cleanses or the cold plunge or, you know, what helps you get through the day? What helps you get through stressful moments? Mm-hmm. For me, it's talking it out. Mm-hmm.|||这样的情况。然后，是的，这取决于具体的场景。但我也还在慢慢熟悉它。对我来说这是一个全新的过程。这是一则来自 BetterHelp 的广告。你知道，感觉现在生活中的方方面面都有人给你提建议。比如，你会写日记吗？你会进行我不知道的排毒调理或是冰浴吗？你知道的，什么能帮你度过这一天？什么能帮你度过压力重重的时刻？嗯。对我来说，就是把心里话说出来。嗯。
Well, there can be a lot of information overload about mental health and wellness, and it can be a struggle to know what's true and what actions to take these days. So you might think about using a trusted resource and talking to live therapists through BetterHelp. It has an app store rating of 4.9 out of 5 based on over 1.7 million client reviews. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Talk it out with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's BetterHelp-H-E-L-P.com slash office ladies. Searchlight Pictures presents The Roses, only in theaters August 29th.
Well, there can be a lot of information overload about mental health and wellness, and it can be a struggle to know what's true and what actions to take these days. So you might think about using a trusted resource and talking to live therapists through BetterHelp. It has an app store rating of 4.9 out of 5 based on over 1.7 million client reviews. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Talk it out with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's BetterHelp-H-E-L-P.com slash office ladies. Searchlight Pictures presents The Roses, only in theaters August 29th.|||嗯，关于心理健康和养生，可能会有大量的信息过载，如今要弄清楚什么是真的、该采取什么行动可能会是一件很纠结的事。所以你可以考虑使用一个值得信赖的资源，通过 BetterHelp 与真人治疗师交流。根据 170 多万客户的评价，它在应用商店获得了 4.9 分的高分（满分 5 分）。作为全球最大的在线心理治疗提供商，BetterHelp 可以为你联系到拥有多种专业知识的心理健康专业人士。通过 BetterHelp 把心事倾诉出来吧。我们的听众在 BetterHelp.com/officeladies 注册第一个月可享 9 折优惠。网址是 BetterHelp-H-E-L-P.com/officeladies。探照灯影业呈献《The Roses》，8 月 29 日仅限影院上映。
From the director of Meet the Parents and the writer of Poor Things comes The Roachers. Roses starring Academy Award winner Olivia Coleman Academy Award nominee Benedict Cumberbatch Andy Samburg, Kate McKinnon, and Allison Janney. A hilarious new comedy filled with drama, excitement, and a little bit of hatred, proving that marriage isn't always a bed of roses. See the roses only in theaters August 29th. What is your background as an actor? Can you tell us a little bit about your training and all that? My training, I can tell you about very quickly because I have none. But I, I, my father is an actor and I like fell into it in that really lucky way that is unfair, basically.
From the director of Meet the Parents and the writer of Poor Things comes The Roachers. Roses starring Academy Award winner Olivia Coleman Academy Award nominee Benedict Cumberbatch Andy Samburg, Kate McKinnon, and Allison Janney. A hilarious new comedy filled with drama, excitement, and a little bit of hatred, proving that marriage isn't always a bed of roses. See the roses only in theaters August 29th. What is your background as an actor? Can you tell us a little bit about your training and all that? My training, I can tell you about very quickly because I have none. But I, I, my father is an actor and I like fell into it in that really lucky way that is unfair, basically.|||曾执导《拜见岳父大人》的导演与《可怜的东西》的编剧联手打造《The Roachers》。由奥斯卡奖得主奥利维娅·科尔曼、奥斯卡奖提名者本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇、安迪·萨姆伯格、凯特·麦克金农和艾莉森·珍妮主演的电影《Roses》。这是一部充满戏剧性、刺激感和一点点怨恨的爆笑新喜剧，证明了婚姻并不总是玫瑰园。8 月 29 日，锁定各大影院观看《Roses》。你作为演员的背景是什么？能跟我们简单讲讲你的培训经历之类的吗？我的培训经历，我可以非常快地讲完，因为我根本没有什么培训经历。但是，我……我父亲是一名演员，我呢，就是以那种非常幸运、基本上很不公平的方式踏入这行的。
But I read a script at Martin McDonough when I was like 19, his agent sent me a script. And I did that. So I auditioned for it and got the first. part and did that in London and in the West End and then went to Broadway once I was done with college. Can you say the name of the play? Yeah, it was called the Lieutenant of Inish Moore and it was like a lot of Tony nominations and it was a very successful play. And then after that took a big dip in terms of I think that quality of written work is so rare that actually I wasn't built to make the most out of scripts that weren't that great after that because I was spoiled. And so,
But I read a script at Martin McDonough when I was like 19, his agent sent me a script. And I did that. So I auditioned for it and got the first. part and did that in London and in the West End and then went to Broadway once I was done with college. Can you say the name of the play? Yeah, it was called the Lieutenant of Inish Moore and it was like a lot of Tony nominations and it was a very successful play. And then after that took a big dip in terms of I think that quality of written work is so rare that actually I wasn't built to make the most out of scripts that weren't that great after that because I was spoiled. And so,|||但我大约 19 岁时读过马丁·麦克唐纳的一个剧本，他的经纪人给我发了一个剧本。然后我就演了。所以我去试镜并拿到了第一个角色，在伦敦和西区演了那部戏，大学毕业后就去了百老汇。你能说一下这部话剧的名字吗？可以，它叫《伊尼什莫尔的中尉》，获得了好多托尼奖提名，是一部非常成功的话剧。在那之后，我的事业经历了一个低谷，因为我觉得那种高质量的剧作实在是太罕见了，事实上，我当时并没有能力把之后那些没那么出色的剧本发挥到极致，因为我被惯坏了。所以，
Yeah. So then things slowed down and then slowly built back up. And then I started doing more movies and stuff like that. And that's been great. I've been very, like, incredibly lucky. I can't believe that your first job in the business was a Martin McDonough play in the West End. I just need you to repeat that for me one more time. It was that. And actually, I don't think I would be an actor if I hadn't read that. That script was the funniest thing I'd ever. ever read, which is insane. So I just read it all the time for fun. I wasn't, I was getting ready for an audition. But when I read it, I was like, imagine being able to do that. That is the funniest thing I've ever read. It was a, it was a very dark comedy about the IRA in Ireland, like about
Yeah. So then things slowed down and then slowly built back up. And then I started doing more movies and stuff like that. And that's been great. I've been very, like, incredibly lucky. I can't believe that your first job in the business was a Martin McDonough play in the West End. I just need you to repeat that for me one more time. It was that. And actually, I don't think I would be an actor if I hadn't read that. That script was the funniest thing I'd ever. ever read, which is insane. So I just read it all the time for fun. I wasn't, I was getting ready for an audition. But when I read it, I was like, imagine being able to do that. That is the funniest thing I've ever read. It was a, it was a very dark comedy about the IRA in Ireland, like about|||是的。然后事情就慢了下来，接着又慢慢重回正轨。后来我开始拍更多电影之类的。这真的很棒。我一直……简直是幸运得难以置信。我真不敢相信你在这行的第一份工作居然是西区马丁·麦克唐纳的一部话剧。我需要你再为我重复一遍。就是那样。事实上，要不是读了那个剧本，我觉得我不会成为一名演员。那个剧本是我读过的……最有趣的东西，这太疯狂了。所以我总是为了好玩而反复读它。我不是……我当时正在为试镜做准备。但当我读到它时，我想，想象一下能演这个该多好。那是我读过的最有趣的剧本。这是一部……这是一部关于爱尔兰共和军的非常黑暗的喜剧，就像是关于
terrorism. So it's darkest subject matter as you can get basically. And yet it was the funniest, most punk rock thing I never read. I love that play. I love him as a writer. I saw, I saw, a production of it. Not with you, unfortunately. I wish I had, but it is, that's pretty freaking cool
terrorism. So it's darkest subject matter as you can get basically. And yet it was the funniest, most punk rock thing I never read. I love that play. I love him as a writer. I saw, I saw, a production of it. Not with you, unfortunately. I wish I had, but it is, that's pretty freaking cool|||恐怖主义的。所以这基本上是你能接触到的最黑暗的题材。然而它却是我读过的最有趣、最朋克摇滚的作品。我很喜欢那部话剧。我很欣赏他作为作家的才华。我看过……我看过它的一个制作版本。可惜不是你演的。我真希望当时能看到你演的，不过这……这真是酷毙了
that that was your first acting role. Yeah, the last scene in that play is me and another character cutting up, cutting up the bodies of everybody else who's been in the play
that that was your first acting role. Yeah, the last scene in that play is me and another character cutting up, cutting up the bodies of everybody else who's been in the play|||那是你的第一个表演角色。是的，那部戏的最后一幕是我和另一个角色在分尸，把戏里出现过的所有其他人的尸体
up to that point. It's a very bloody ending. The lights come up and just its body parts everywhere and we're like literally cutting bodies up, which is incredibly grisly, but it is,
up to that point. It's a very bloody ending. The lights come up and just its body parts everywhere and we're like literally cutting bodies up, which is incredibly grisly, but it is,|||碎尸万段。这是一个非常血腥的结局。灯光亮起，到处都是身体的残肢断臂，我们真的在现场分尸，这极其毛骨悚然，但它……
I've never, still have not heard a reaction from an audience like it. When the lights would come up, it was like, gasps and people saying holy shit and what like people like it didn't feel like
I've never, still have not heard a reaction from an audience like it. When the lights would come up, it was like, gasps and people saying holy shit and what like people like it didn't feel like|||我从来没有、至今也从未听到过观众有这样的反应。当灯光亮起时，全场一片倒吸凉气声，人们惊呼“卧槽”什么的，就好像大家觉得……
what I knew what I thought the theater was it felt so vital and so funny and yeah love Martin would you would you like to do more theatre? I mean I've kept it up over the years but I'd say once every sort of three or four years so the last two plays I did were by
what I knew what I thought the theater was it felt so vital and so funny and yeah love Martin would you would you like to do more theatre? I mean, I've kept it up over the years but I'd say once every sort of three or four years so the last two plays I did were by|||这和我所了解、我以为的戏剧完全不同，它感觉充满生命力又极其搞笑，是的，我太爱马丁了。你……你还想演更多话剧吗？我的意思是，这些年来我一直在坚持演，但大概每三四年才演一次吧，所以我演的最后两部话剧是出自
another genius of Irish playwriting called Enda Walsh one of those was a big verse and one of those was an absolute very funny moments in a bit of real tragedy. He's another genius. So yeah, yeah, I like doing theater once every three or four years. Do you have sort of a dark sense of humor if you're sort of drawn to that? Because I know I love dark comedy, but is that something like you particularly like yourself? Most certainly. I would say that's probably where most of my, yeah, that's what I would
another genius of Irish playwriting called Enda Walsh one of those was a big verse and one of those was an absolute very funny moments in a bit of real tragedy. He's another genius. So yeah, yeah, I like doing theater once every three or four years. Do you have sort of a dark sense of humor if you're sort of drawn to that? Because I know I love dark comedy, but is that something like you particularly like yourself? Most certainly. I would say that's probably where most of my, yeah, that's what I would|||爱尔兰另一位戏剧创作天才恩达·沃尔什之手。其中一部是一首长诗，另一部则充满了非常搞笑的时刻和一丝真正的悲剧色彩。他也是另一位天才。所以，是的，是的，我喜欢每三四年演一次话剧。如果你对这种黑色幽默情有独钟，你是不是有一种黑暗的幽默感？因为我知道我很喜欢黑色喜剧，但这是否也是你特别喜欢的东西？毫无疑问。我会说那可能是我大部分……是的，那是我
laugh at most. And that's funny then because Ned in this is not a dark character at all. He's very optimistic and all that. So it's actually coming from a different place, which is, which is, again, really fun. This is a question, and I don't know if it applies to this story because we don't know much about it, but we would do so many scenes in a conference room and we would be there all day for five days in a tiny room and you get punchy, you start to overshare. And do you have in this show, is there a space where you all gather? Well, we have our own sort of conference room, sort of a setup. And any time when we are there, that's where we'll kind of hang out in between. But actually, I think, is our set bigger than your set? Much, much bigger.
laugh at most. And that's funny then because Ned in this is not a dark character at all. He's very optimistic and all that. So it's actually coming from a different place, which is, which is, again, really fun. This is a question, and I don't know if it applies to this story because we don't know much about it, but we would do so many scenes in a conference room and we would be there all day for five days in a tiny room and you get punchy, you start to overshare. And do you have in this show, is there a space where you all gather? Well, we have our own sort of conference room, sort of a setup. And any time when we are there, that's where we'll kind of hang out in between. But actually, I think, is our set bigger than your set? Much, much bigger.|||最常笑点所在。那就很有趣了，因为《The Paper》里的内德一点也不黑暗。他非常乐观诸如此类的。所以这实际上是出于一个不同的出发点，这真的、真的很有趣。这是一个问题，我不知道它是否适用于这个故事，因为我们对它了解不多，但我们以前会在会议室里拍很多场戏，我们在那个小房间里一待就是一整天，连续待五天，人就会变得情绪亢奋，开始过度分享。在这部剧中，你们有这样一个大家聚集在一起的空间吗？嗯，我们有我们自己的那种会议室，算是那种布景吧。每当我们在那里时，那就是我们在拍戏间隙闲逛的地方。但实际上，我觉得，我们的布景比你们的布景更大吗？大得多，大得多。
So there's not quite the same thing of being on top of each other. There's a lot of kind of, but like, yes, you end up with sort of groups chatting depending on who's in. And actually, as it's gone along, there are not lots of days where everybody's in at the same time. I mean, there might be one day a week when everybody's in the same time, for the most part, we're kind of spread out and slightly separate storylines. But yeah, it's such a lovely group. It's very nice to hang out when we've died. Do you have to do a lot of background work for other people's scenes? Like, do you have to sit at your desk a lot and just kind of be busy? So yes, it certainly happens, but my desk is, or my office is over in the corner and is hidden away from a lot of the bullpen.
So there's not quite the same thing of being on top of each other. There's a lot of kind of, but like, yes, you end up with sort of groups chatting depending on who's in. And actually, as it's gone along, there are not lots of days where everybody's in at the same time. I mean, might be one day a week when everybody's in the same time, for the most part, we're kind of spread out and slightly separate storylines. But yeah, it's such a lovely group. It's very nice to hang out when we've died. Do you have to do a lot of background work for other people's scenes? Like, do you have to sit at your desk a lot and just kind of be busy? So yes, it certainly happens, but my desk is, or my office is over in the corner and is hidden away from a lot of the bullpen.|||所以不会有那种挤在一起的感觉。会有很多那种……不过，是的，根据谁在场，最后大家会三五成群地聊天。事实上，随着拍摄的进行，全员同时到齐的日子并不多。我的意思是，可能一周有一天所有人都在场，但大多数情况下，我们都是分散开的，各自的故事线也稍微有些独立。不过，是的，这是一个非常可爱的剧组。收工后一起聚聚感觉非常棒。你们需要为别人的场景做很多背景工作吗？比如，你得经常坐在办公桌前假装很忙吗？是的，这确实会发生，但我的办公桌，或者说我的办公室在角落里，离开放式办公区很远，藏在后面。
so you could be passing through stuff or you could be there in the background of certain shots but yeah everybody does background work for everybody else but my character tends to be on or off there's not a lot of middle of territory. You're so lucky. When you saw that desk, were you just so pleased? You're like, oh, sweet, I'm not going to be in the background
so you could be passing through stuff or you could be there in the background of certain shots but yeah everybody does background work for everybody else but my character tends to be on or off there's not a lot of middle of territory. You're so lucky. When you saw that desk, were you just so pleased? You're like, oh, sweet, I'm not going to be in the background|||所以你可能会路过一些地方，或者在某些镜头的背景里出现。但是的，每个人都会为其他人做背景工作，不过我的角色往往要么出场要么退场，没有太多中间地带。你太幸运了。当你看到那个办公桌时，你是不是高兴坏了？你当时是不是想：“太棒了，我不用在背景里呆着了”
of half the day. Depending which way they're shooting. Yeah, I mean, you know, They're still like, you know, you're in, I mean, yeah, I'm in most the time. So yeah, yeah. I know. I would think, oh, I'm not in this scene. I'm tiny. I'm behind the partition. No one's going to see me. And they'd be like, Angela's at the copier. I'm like, again, like, how many times is my character at the copier? I remember talking to Will Arnett about Arrested Development. And he said that had a really big cast. And if you watch later seasons of Arrested Development, he said, you'll see that like five of us,
of half the day. Depending which way they're shooting. Yeah, I mean, you know, They're still like, you know, you're in, I mean, yeah, I'm in most the time. So yeah, yeah. I know. I would think, oh, I'm not in this scene. I'm tiny. I'm behind the partition. No one's going to see me. And they'd be like, Angela's at the copier. I'm like, again, like, how many times is my character at the copier? I remember talking to Will Arnett about Arrested Development. And he said that had a really big cast. And if you watch later seasons of Arrested Development, he said, you'll see that like five of us,|||呆上半天。这取决于他们拍摄的方向。是的，我的意思是，你知道的，他们仍然……你知道的，你在线，我的意思是，是的，我大部分时间都在出场。所以，是的，是的。我懂。我以前会想：“哦，我没在这场戏里。我很渺小。我在隔断后面。没人会看到我。”然后他们就会说：“安吉拉在复印机旁。”我就想：“又来？我的角色到底要去复印机旁多少次？”我记得我和威尔·阿奈特聊起《发展受阻》时，他说那部剧的演员阵容非常庞大。如果你看《发展受阻》后面的几季，他说，你会发现我们大概有五个人，
are all stacked in a line because we didn't want to have to do more than like two setups of coverage. He's like, so later seasons of arrested development, we realized our days could be shorter if we all just bunch up in a line and talk to the other character. So it'll be like all of the children. Rather, they used to spread out around the room, but then they'd have to cover it. And he was like, we shaved a good three, four hours off our days. Like everyone's singing the national anthem. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's funny. Yeah, yeah. It's funny. Yeah, no, there's definitely, yeah, there's definitely days like that on this, but it's, I think we all knew, like, Greg, it's your show. Like, we all knew the deal. Like, you're, you're kind of signing up for an office job. You're kind of signing up for office hours when you sign up the job. That's just, that's just part of it. So I don't mind. And also, you're signing up for last minute script changes, last minute scripts. We would get scripts and we'd have a table read and we think that's what we're shooting. And I'd start. to memorize my lines and then in hair and makeup,
are all stacked in a line because we didn't want to have to do more than like two setups of coverage. He's like, so later seasons of arrested development, we realized our days could be shorter if we all just bunch up in a line and talk to the other character. So it'll be like all of the children. Rather, they used to spread out around the room, but then they'd have to cover it. And he was like, we shaved a good three, four hours off our days. Like everyone's singing the national anthem. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's funny. Yeah, yeah. It's funny. Yeah, no, there's definitely, yeah, there's definitely days like that on this, but it's, I think we all knew, like, Greg, it's your show. Like, we all knew the deal. Like, you're, you're kind of signing up for an office job. You're kind of signing up for office hours when you sign up the job. That's just, that's just part of it. So I don't mind. And also, you're signing up for last minute script changes, last minute scripts. We would get scripts and we'd have a table read and we think that's what we're shooting. And I'd start. to memorize my lines and then in hair and makeup,|||全都排成一整条线站着，因为我们不想做超过两个机位的覆盖拍摄。他说，所以到了《发展受阻》的后几季，我们意识到，如果我们全都挤成一排跟另一个角色对话，我们的工作时间就能缩短。所以就会像所有的孩子们一样。而不是像以前那样散落在房间各处，那样的话就必须进行多机位覆盖拍摄。他说，我们这样把每天的工作时间缩减了足足三四个小时。就像每个人都在唱国歌一样。对，对，对。太逗了。对，对。太逗了。对，没有，这里确实……是的，这部剧里肯定也有这样的日子，但是，我觉得我们大家都知道，就像格雷格说的，这是你的节目。我们都知道规矩。当你接下这份工作时，你其实就是在一份办公室工作上签字画押。当你接下这份工作时，你其实就是在朝九晚五的办公时间上签字画押。这只是其中的一部分。所以我并不介意。而且，你还得接受最后一刻的剧本修改、最后一刻送来的剧本。我们拿到剧本并进行围读，以为我们拍的就是这个。然后我开始背台词，接着在发型和化妆间里，
they'd hand me a different scene or some weeks. We would start the week with a few scenes and get the full script on Wednesday, bonkers. But that's the madness of it. But also, I think the genius of Greg, too. Yeah, for sure. Yeah, I think for the most part, we got our script Saturday before we should start on the Monday.
they'd hand me a different scene or some weeks. We would start the week with a few scenes and get the full script on Wednesday, bonkers. But that's the madness of it. But also, I think the genius of Greg, too. Yeah, for sure. Yeah, I think for the most part, we got our script Saturday before we should start on the Monday.|||他们会递给我一个不同的场景，或者有时候某些周。我们一周开始时只有几个场景，周三才能拿到完整的剧本，太疯狂了。但这正是它的疯狂之处。不过，我也觉得这也是格雷格的天才之处。是的，确实如此。是的，我觉得大多数情况下，我们在周一开拍前的周六就能拿到剧本。
So that's the weekend. What you do is prepare for the week. And then there's changes that kind of come along as we go. But like it changes all the time. And again, I think there's the whole process is new. It's new for Greg, you know, because it's him and Come and making it now and a whole new cast of characters and stuff like that.
So that's the weekend. What you do is prepare for the week. And then there's changes that kind of come along as we go. But like it changes all the time. And again, I think there's the whole process is new. It's new for Greg, you know, because it's him and Come and making it now and a whole new cast of characters and stuff like that.|||所以那个周末。你要做的事就是为这一周做准备。然后随着拍摄的进行，会有各种修改。但感觉剧本一直在变。而且再次我觉得整个过程都是崭新的。对格雷格来说是崭新的，你知道的，因为现在是他和柯姆在制作这部剧，还有全新的一批演员阵容诸如此类的。
So it's all, I think we're just finding our way and finding what makes the show take, you know. Well, we can't wait to see it. I'm so excited. This has been so wonderful. Thank you for taking your time out of your day. And we're really big fans for trying to like be cool. but I don't know how I'm really being cool
So it's all, I think we're just finding our way and finding what makes the show take, you know. Well, we can't wait to see it. I'm so excited. This has been so wonderful. Thank you for taking your time out of your day. And we're really big fans for trying to like be cool. but I don't know how I'm really being cool|||所以这一切，我觉得我们只是在摸索前行，寻找让这部剧运转起来的秘诀，你知道的。好吧，我们已经迫不及待想看了。我太激动了。这次访谈太棒了。谢谢你百忙之中抽出时间。而且我们真的是超级粉丝，一直在努力装酷。但我不知道我到底有没有装酷成功，
because you're just really an amazing talent. And so thank you for letting us talk to you. I don't deal well with compliments, but that was incredibly nice of you. You're both wonderful and your show is wonderful. And it feels so dumb in a way to be doing a show that has anything to do with that because you did your show so well and so beautifully.
because you're just really an amazing talent. And so thank you for letting us talk to you. I don't well with compliments, but that was incredibly nice of you. You're both wonderful and your show is wonderful. And it feels so dumb in a way to be doing a show that has anything to do with that because you did your show so well and so beautifully.|||因为你真的太有才华了。所以谢谢你让我们采访你。我不太擅长接受赞美，但你这话真是太暖心了。你们俩都很棒，你们的剧也很棒。从某种角度来看，去做一部跟那部剧有任何关联的剧感觉有点愚蠢，因为你们把你们的剧拍得太棒、太完美了。
and hopefully we'll make something different enough that people will be able to kind of treat it as its own thing because otherwise there's no winning, you know what I mean? Like what you did was absolutely incredible. So, yeah, thank you for having me on the show. Thank you so much. So fun. I loved his story about when he first met with Greg and Michael,
and hopefully we'll make something different enough that people will be able to kind of treat it as its own thing because otherwise there's no winning, you know what I mean? Like what you did was absolutely incredible. So, yeah, thank you for having me on the show. Thank you so much. So fun. I loved his story about when he first met with Greg and Michael,|||希望我们能拍出足够与众不同的作品，让大家能把它当作一件独立的作品来看待，因为否则的话根本没有胜算，你知道我的意思吗？就像你们做的事情绝对是不可思议的。所以，是的，谢谢邀请我上节目。非常感谢。太有趣了。我特别喜欢他讲的那个故事：当他第一次与格雷格和迈克尔会面时，
how he said at one point they weren't sure who was interviewing who. Yes, that was very. funny. And I just loved geeking out with him over theater. I know you did. I still can't believe that story. I mean, that's wild. Okay, everyone, we hope you enjoyed that. Please join us next Friday for our interview with Chelsea Fry. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicot. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill
how he said at one point they weren't sure who was interviewing who. Yes, that was very. funny. And I just loved geeking out with him over theater. I know you did. I still can't believe that story. I mean, that's wild. Okay, everyone, we hope you enjoyed that. Please join us next Friday for our interview with Chelsea Fry. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicot. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill|||他说他们一度分不清到底是谁在面试谁。是的，那真的太好笑了。我太喜欢和他一起狂热地聊戏剧了。我知道你很喜欢。我还是不敢相信那个故事。我是说，这也太疯狂了。好了，各位，希望你们喜欢这期节目。请下周五继续收听我们对切尔西·弗莱的采访。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Odyssey 出品，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是英斯利·布比科特。Odyssey 的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。本期《办公室女士》由比尔进行混音和母带制作
Schultz. Our theme song is Rupertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Schultz. Our theme song is Rupertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.|||舒尔茨。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rupertree》。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。